[Musique]
m
là juste derrière vous avez le predator
chronos pêche d'énormes machines
[Musique]
premier jour à berlin je suis arrivé
hier soir était 23 heures et quelques et
là c'est plutôt pas mal donc on est
parti ça y est pour un if à 2018 avoir
pas mal de choses aller vers ça va être
super cool plein de choses à visiter là
c'est le matin 8h42 dure et perdure
parce que assez peu dormi fugue de ce
jusqu'à 1h30 du matin puis la rituelle
oblige et je vous faire visiter un petit
peu ma gueule je crois ne t'aime pas
coup je trouve qu'elle quitte pas mal
plutôt cool je voulais dire ça peut être
hotel for youth regard des petites
fioles sympathique ça petit lit vue sur
l'extérieur là on n'est pas loin de la
séparation
sa venue à berlin il ya là des lignes au
sol qui vous marquent vraiment l'endroit
où passait le mur et l'amba qui a des
infos sur le mur qui devait passer par
là enfin ça je voudrais faire un petit
tour à chaque fois donc on regardera ça
plus en détails donc ça c'est plutôt pas
mal que tokyo y regarder c'est assez
cosy sympathique puis les salles de
bains franchement je sais que c'est à
une attaque mais c'est quand même cool
de visite un petit peu voilà de beaux
lots j'adore la baignoire
et puis voilà comme ça tout le monde que
vous mettez en train de vous laver c'est
super cool
l'étoile est bien évidemment aujourd'hui
je vais commencer avec la quine de acer
on a un événement asus nietzsche ou
pendant le putsch est sous embargo
on a aussi un événement rare qui s'est
pourtant pour le coup de fil c'est
souvent dorbeaux et j'ai rendez vous
avec un des big boss de dell pour parler
de la marque donc à pas mal de choses
tout sera pas publiée aujourd'hui parce
que forcément pas le temps vous aurez
peut-être des bribes sauf ce qui est
souvent borgo parce que j'ai pas le
droit
et voilà allez
[Musique]
bien arriver devant mais ce mais ces
messieurs mais ce rôle pan allemand
berlin c'est là où se déroulera en fait
c'est là où se déroule le grand salon de
l'ifa la ja les installations parce que
pendant quelques jours on est quel jour
aujourd'hui on est je vais choisir les
mercredis donc mercredi jeudi vendredi
ce sont les media day donc des journées
uniquement ouverte à la presse
absolument pas ouvertes au grand public
ça ouvre au grand public à partir de
samedi jusqu'à jeudi peut-être vendredi
de la semaine prochaine
donc moi je vais couvrir ces media days
mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi j'ai faim
la première ouverture au public donc là
on va commencer
et bien vous allez entrer à l'intérieur
on va les voir ce qui se passe et puis
voir ce que nous réserve cet ifa 2018
[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le voir là le salon
est en train de se monter
on ne sait pas encore fini on y réussit
en chantier
là on attend le début de la conférence
de acer tout au début des médias des de
l'ifa sais pas si vous voyez c'est
vraiment une lampe vous avez
le petit cocktail dînatoire la
présentation qui aura lieu ici derrière
tout côté un peu
nick
les caméras et pas mal de monde c'est en
train d'arriver il est quelque chose
comme 10 heures dans une des meilleures
ça commencerait cool tout bien sûr je
sais pas ce qu'on va te présenter à
priori plutôt des laptops ce matin pas
de smartphone
de faire aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas mal
de choses donc on va suivre sans
direct presque exactement en profiter'
offre intéressante et d'acer qui nous a
quand même bien régalé cette année
[Musique]
c'est le buzz d'affaires quartiers là
sur la scène
alors l'homme et dans une session un
petit peu interview après la plantation
ya eu plein plein de choses de présenter
on va essayer de grossir un peu tout ça
il ya eu des produits vraiment dédié
pour le gaming des produits ordinateurs
des produits pour les développeurs il
n'y a pas eu pas mal de choses
on va prendre le temps un peu
déconcertant a eu pas mal d'annoncés pas
d'amour smartphone vraiment une grande
matinée ordinateur laptop réalité
virtuelle ça c'est cool on va aussi pas
mal regardé ça parce qu'a priori un
nouveau casque il ya un nouveau casque
qui fait vraiment suivi des vieux donc
vraiment quelque chose de vraiment
optimisé pour la réalité virtuelle et ça
franchement ça la prudence
[Musique]
on est avec karim qui est directeur
marketing acer france 9 ans karim 2
par len concevoir plaisir alors il
beaucoup dénoncent le fait aujourd'hui à
l'ifa est ce que tu peux m'aider un peu
démêler tout ça parce que effectivement
et du pc + laptop travail
la pc gaming et respectent des normes
machine pour le gaming du casque vert il
y en a tellement qui en fait il ya eu ce
matin annonce sur le grand public sur le
gaming mais aussi sur la partie on veut
dire une frite oui on a présenté le
nouveau casque s'avère qui permet
d'avoir une immersion assez inédite
jamais eu lieu avec un angle de vue de
plus de 110 degrés est quelque chose
d'assez incroyable
voici donc star verte on dit casque de
verre case de réalité virtuelle
complètement incroyable pour
l'utilisation surtout professionnel dieu
est avec un champ de vision qui est
hyper réaliste puisque c'est le chant
vision que l'on a
sur le cumin sur l'humain donc on est un
peu plus de deux cent dix degrés donc
c'est quelque chose d'assez bluff
il faut laisser au moins devant les cei
je vais rentrer alors ça c'est plus du
destine aux professionnels
oui c'est un casque vous retrouver pour
le particulier et encore et encore pour
les particuliers on a annoncé le casque
mitraillette qui aux jo 500 way qui est
un casque qui suit la lignée des casques
mistral ici windows mais qui est
détachable qui est une nouveauté et qui
a le sont intégrés aux seahawks évoquant
la manière dont on a pu adresser un
casque pour le grand public avec une
meneuse et l'évolution c'est ce casque
des achats vers les gets 450 grammes à
peu près facilement réglable avec
justement cette technologie audio qui
vient se mettre directement au dessus
des oreilles et la possibilité
maintenant de détacher vont nettoyer les
lentilles c'est des mousses rigides ou
plutôt moelleuse qui peuvent être passé
à la machine si on a besoin de nettoyer
donc c'est plus hygiénique et produisent
âge professionnels ses besoins un casque
de réalité mixte pack de vin était
virtuel et réalité virtuelle annonce que
de réalité virtuelle et ça marche donc
ça qu'on peut utiliser sur n'importe
quelle machine pour faire du gaming et
ça sans problème on appelle mme x
reality puisqu'il est compatible avec
toutes les solutions de réalité
virtuelle à travers la trace windows
disent ok mais saint cast réalité
virtuelle
cool bon alors ça c'est pour le casque
de l'air ensuite on arrive aux
ordinateurs sur le grand public les
ordinateurs portables avec la gamme
aspire qui évolue avec les bords
ultra-fin voyais à la mise à jour des
specs avec les processeurs intel core i7
huitième génération hope town donc
toutes ces technologies qui arrive dans
le grand public c'est aussi skoda
annonce présentée avec le all in one qui
est moi je trouve un petit bijou sens en
bordure avec nouvelles technologies opta
d'intel core i7 génération 8 est
vraiment ca
'l'annonce qu'on a fait autour qui est
autour de alex ahad cortana qui sont
maintenant compatibles sur ces produits
de septième génération sur la même
machine tu as alexa ray cortana possible
avec ça what is the weather et donc
ensuite un autre produit le souich de 7
celui de sète qui est un vrai bijou en
fait je me suis tout de suite 5 et 7 et
les deux sont dans chaque dans leurs
catégories soit le plus léger du monde
presque cinq mois le plus fin du monde
ou presque de cette non seulement une
série de produits assez incroyable donc
je suis sain qui est un pc qui pèse
moins d'un kilo
1 920
c'est rendu possible grâce au lithium
est on
et au magnésium faux châssis qui est
extrêmement léger extrêmement léger et
hyper robuste ce que l'idée n'était pas
de rappeler ces fins des fragiles oui
donc ça reste robuste mais très très
léger et on est super fiable à la basse
à 14 ou somme a réussi à rendre 15
pouces sans rajouter du poids et a pu
920 de foot 7
qui encore
bull devient 14 pouces mais ultra fin et
avec dalles d'écrans qui représente 92 %
de la surface
pour qu'on voit quasiment pas les bords
cinq ans c'est une prouesse puisque voit
toujours réservé des espaces par heymans
et les côtés ils ont réussi à faire un
écran quasiment samba 14 pouces ultra
fin et on a vu sur scène c'est bluffant
on ne voit quasiment pas quand les
dauphines et ensuite la party gaming et
là on a présenté le site on 900 wii qui
apporte cette nouveauté de deux fois
amenez l'écran à soi ou de pouvoir leur
tournée ou de voir le transformant votre
tablette donc c'est l'évolution de 87
cents avec en plus la ventilation qui a
évolué dans sa quatrième génération
d'aero blade qui permet d'avoir une
meilleure ventilation et la mise à jouer
avec les cartes graphiques rtx la
louisiane ouais on peut tout on va
parler à la semaine dernière avec leur
conférence elles vont maintenant équiper
notre série de sutton et le 900 apporte
justement cette possibilité avec l'écran
qui peut se déplacer comme ça alors
l'utilité parce que moi je sais pas
gamer à la base j'ai un peu
son patron forcément toujours l'unité
mais le fait d'avoir l'écran qui bouge
on va pas en terme d'expérience gaming
ce que ça va apporter quelque chose ou
est ce que c'est plus pour vraiment
avoir quelque chose de modulable ouais
c'est les deux il yad'un côté immersion
quand on rapproche les crops le clavier
vers le bas sur le triton on peut
rapprocher l'écran pour être un peu plus
près de l'action
et il ya aussi un module pour les
manettes xbox qui sont connectables
directement à sans avoir un bon vieux
supplémentaires hockey et du coup on
peut imaginer de retourner les crampons
à voir que retourner le pc pendant que
l'écran passe d'accord on est en mode
console entre guillemets avec l'image
est boxé à vraiment l'utilisation qui
est adaptable et l'immersion qui est
beaucoup plus importante que tout
rapproche l'écran pour votre joie ok
cool cool hors ces éléments pour toutes
à steenbecque et l or ensuite on a des
dates fixes
predator x qui est à le tout premier
première voie que celle chen deming en
gros qui est basée sur deux cpu qui dit
cpu faisait on sait des choses hyper
costaud avec douce note pour la ram donc
bon si on était technicien on se rend
compte un peu détendu des performances
pour avoir dû subir et c'est une machine
qui est fait à la fois pour ceux qui
réalisent du contenu vidéo du groupe
plus graphique est ce qu'on voit aussi
beaucoup énergie des joueurs puisque rim
aussi en parallèle elle typhon du
montage vidéo et avec ce type de machine
ils peuvent tout faire sans avoir de
baisse de performance on est vraiment
sur la gamme predator donc on a le 9
milles de 5000 et de trouville en fait
c'est vrai c'est vraiment la gamme de
produits pour les joueurs hyper
exigeants qui ont besoin de perdre
puissance brute
après on a les nouveautés sur les
nouveaux modèles dorion avec les cartes
graphiques et rtx donc la série vin de
chez nokia
et en plus de ça on en a profité pour
ajouter à côté un peu plus cosmétique
avec le rgb sur les leds convoi en phase
aller sur le ventillo après en fonction
de l'usagé qu'on va avoir et en fonction
des besoins
alors soit 9000 qui combine un peu le
truc extrême processeur core i9 puce
avec avec la techno opstaan de gpu etc
mais ça c'est vraiment pour ceux qui
veulent avant l'incroyable et après en
fonction des modèles on va voir le
joueur un peu plus exigeants qui va
avoir besoin d'un core i7 et d'une 10 90
70 et en fonction des modèles on va
comme ça évolue et nous on est sûr de
huitième génération et sur la geforce
rtx et après ce qui est toujours pas mal
de suspect
toujours le petit support ici pour pour
les casques allemand s'il est pas
casque dessus si tu veux être comme ça
des petits techno qui se rajouter dessus
la ventilation aussi sur quelques gros
efforts sur des machines un peu
d'exceptions légale ni trop c'est la
gamme de gaming a certes on n'est pas
celui predator on est sur du acer c'est
une gamme gaming qui est plus abordable
avec un peu moins de techno que ce qu'on
a sur du prédateur mais avec toute
expertise acer donc ça reste quelque
chose de très fiable mais c'est pour les
joueurs qui savent exactement quels jeux
ils veulent jouer et quelle perf ils
veulent exactement sans forcément aller
plus haut là on est sur une machine qui
est parfaite pour jouer du force night
at the king of legends
on est sur des conflits qui sont en 10
70 70 pour certaines filles mais
généralement on est sur du core i5 core
i7 10,60 jusqu'à 8 ou 12 giga de ram et
des bonnes machines pour jouer à la
majorité des jeux si on est un hardcore
gamer et qu'on joue dix heures par jour
mieux vaut être sûr que predator puis à
l'éthique nous supplémentaires mais si
on est un joueur un peu que ce qu'on dit
cajole la gamme lytro c'est la gamme par
cette fois et on arrive après sur votre
sur le tonneau stone le tonneau ce qui
est le siège des mineurs çà c'est
l'apple la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
tous les ans d'un produit est incroyable
il y avait le vent tahiti qui avait
accusé le portable incurvé 21 pouces là
on part sur notre dos qui est un
fauteuil gaming
qui est qui peut recevoir jusqu'à trois
écrans et 3 écran 24 pouces un corps et
27 pouces accordé par des 14 et qui
totalement motorisés donc on s'installe
dessus on lance sa config et le siège
vallée automatiquement se se cambrer
vers l'arrière on va pouvoir jouer à
tous les jeux de manière hyper immersive
et ce qui est différente
sympa c'est que le fauteuil réagit aussi
dans l'accord des biberons quand tu va
réagir sur les basses en fonction de
l'action en fonction du jeu donc on est
occupé à immerger entier
c'est pas destiné à nous à ce genre de
solution
tout le monde va pas se l'offrir sur du
green earth est vraiment soit traîné
chez ivoire pour des équipes déjà une
barrière c'est le coup oui génération va
être disponible en deux versions la
version du fauteuil seule la version du
fauteuil avec la ligue de l'enseignement
ça coûte
après ce sera un livre à l'achat pour
tout le monde voyons pour acheter une
regarde le coup ça va coûter combien on
n'a pas encore les pieds exact auquel
mes machines complètes avec avec tous
les écrans avec la tour et les
périphériques
on va être je pense à ses proches de ce
qui avait été fait à l'époque sur le pc
le 21 août c'est pensable
donc on apporte quoi déprimer ça va être
quelque chose d'assez élevé oui
totalement
alors en termes de disponibilité des
produits qu'on a vu aujourd'hui en
termes de coûts
les produits grand public être
disponible en fin d'année 4 ensuite sur
le très attendu x malheureusement n'a
pas encore la bourse officielle pour le
cas pour le
du coup versant est
pense pouvoir être trade premier
trimestre 2009 ok et
et ensuite pour le tonneau soit pas de
date officielle encore rester connectés
comme ça on en reparle voilà ok cool on
écoute merci boukari merci est ce que tu
vois autre chose à nous
et aujourd'hui
et je suis encore des choses qui
pourraient arriver pas encore d'une
surprise là non là on a vraiment dans
cette wave j'imagine que j'avais là il y
aura d'autres annonces qui vont arriver
pour l'instant blessure lesquels
continuent de travailler mais on attend
que tous vraiment bien canalisée pour
vraiment les présenter mais voilà s'est
connecté vers des choses que l'on
regarde la porte merci à toi merci
là juste derrière vous avez le predator
chronos d'énormes machines pour gamer
alors non ce ne sera pas la porte et ont
mené de semer la typique mans vous avez
des vibrations qui sont dans le dos vous
avez quelque chose qui s'incline un
écran qui passent sur l'avant avec trois
moniteurs sensation gainey à mon avis là
on est quand même un peu dans
l'expérience ultime
si on trouve mieux vaut 1000 yards super
présentation de la serre merci pour le
ndt bac tout va bien et maintenant il
est l'heure de continuer la visite on a
regardé ses continue de se monter
c'est lift en chantier chez un peu perdu
tellement grand ici
[Musique]